the cats out of the bag yeah I am so
excited about this I will be joining as
one of the new coaching boys
Nick Jonas surprising everyone with that
announcement on The Ellen DeGeneres Show
in addition to the competitive spirit
which would be natural because I'm very
competitive right I think I'm actually
looking forward to really trying to help
any artists that comes on the show and
wants to grow of course Ellen had some
surprises for Nick messages from his
fellow coaches hey I'm Kelly here I just
wanted to congratulations I do
definitely feel like the two Texans
should maybe team up and form an
alliance
I'm just saying Nick Jonas is
challenging you new coworker welcome to
The Voice I just have to tell you one
thing our mission is to destroy Blake
Shelton
Blake bean Blake had this to say I have
to look through the rules because this
is my TV show I'm not sure that you're
even old enough to be a coach on the
voice but I'm certain that you're gonna
get your butt kicked buddy but don't
worry
Nick's hired back this week like I'm
gonna kick your ass as weird as it is
Blake that I'm so young it's it's
exciting to have had an out of nearly 20
year career yeah well there there you go
now well we're super happy for Nick a
lot of people are wondering why Gwen
Stefani is the coach being replaced well
Gwen recently announced the final dates
of her just a girl residency in Las
Vegas which takes place in February and
May 2020 the same time as the spring
cycle of the voice I think by now we all
also know that the show rotates coaches
pretty often of course all this news
comes just after Adam Levine explained
why he left the show and a reminder he
was a regular coach on there you know I
miss I really do miss it I love the
people that I met and worked with him
obviously we all know how I feel about
Blake yeah that guy and you know I do
miss it but I also don't miss how much I
had to work you know I was just
constantly working for so many years
very lucky very fortunate very blessed
and all that but
you know just to be able to kind of stop
it in this moment to spend time with my
my new young family and yep and uh just
how the greatest time ever now I'm just
like a stay-at-home dad I just stay home
and do very little now we are all super
excited about this news as is Nick sways
Priyanka it's super exciting I think
Nick just needs to be himself which I'm
going to he knows about music so much
he's literally been a music prodigy
since he was 7 years old so I think
it'll be amazing to see him working with
like new musicians and as he got into
that is he a competitive guys all right
guys what do you think of Nick joining
the voice let me know and for all the
latest on Nick the Jonas Brothers and
the voice stick with et I'm Katie Krauss
and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]